MATT SHEETS: Hello, everyone.
My name is Matt Sheets,
and it's a pleasure for me
to introduce David
Lamfrom to you today.
David is the director of the
California Desert and National
Wildlife programs.
His career has offered him a
diverse set of vantage points
into our country's parklands.
He's worked in the fields
of research biology, where
he focused on aquaculture,
agricultural biology
and herpetology, which
is the study of reptiles
and amphibians.
After this, he spent three years
as an environmental consultant
working in his home
state of Florida.
He's authored a book on
tortoises in the Mojave Desert
and has leveraged
his photography
to help document
and build awareness
of the diverse wildlife
which fills our parklands
and deserts.
Today, as the director
of California Desert
and the National
Wildlife programs,
David has dedicated both his
professional and personal lives
to inspiring others to
learn about and protect
our wild lands, which brings
us to the topic for the today,
which is President Obama's
recent designation of three
new national monuments
in the California desert.
Without further ado, I'd
like to introduce David.
DAVID LAMFROM: So I'm
going to talk to you today
about a couple of things.
The first thing is I'm going
to talk to you about deserts
in general and why they matter.
And I'm going to talk to
you about one of the truly,
I think, remarkable
things that's
happened in recent
history, which
is the designation
of a vast swath
of the beautiful
California desert
in perpetuity connecting an
incredibly large landscape
together.
But before I do that, I'm
going to tell you a story.
So everybody can see this
lizard that's on the screen.
This is a baby desert iguana.
So most people don't know
and some people wouldn't even
care, necessarily, that
the state of California
has its own iguana.
So like the green iguana you
would think of in Costa Rica,
we have a desert-adapted
species of iguana.
And I grew up in very
urban south Florida.
And basically, for
my entire life,
I was fascinated for,
at least at the time,
no good reason to
the Mojave Desert.
I was just fascinated.
I wanted to know everything
about that place.
about the animals that
lived there.
And I was especially
interested in the reptiles
that lived there, because
they were just so fascinating.
And they just did
different things
than animals in
other places did.
So for example, these lizards
that live in the Mojave Desert,
many of them are vegetarians.
And a whole bunch of
them-- actually, there's
a whole hierarchy
of these lizards.
And the smaller ones
have adapted the ability
to run on two legs
to elude predators.
And then the bigger lizards
that chase those lizards run
on two legs, kind of like
a miniature Jurassic Park
happening all across the
California desert, which
to me was so fascinating.
But as I had the
incredible privilege
of living in the
California desert
and becoming a
wildlife photographer
and getting to know
the place, the thing
I realized about this
desert is so often, it
exists in its fullness
right before your eyes,
and it's oftentimes extremely
difficult to really see it.
And it's a subtle place.
And it's a place that's governed
by incredibly long periods
of time, and then spectacular,
dramatic things happen.
I was reminded of this.
I was reminded of innovation.
I was reminded of the
diversity of the desert
when I was reviewing
some of my photos
and I looked at this photo.
I was looking at
this desert iguana.
And for many, many years
when I looked at this photo,
I always liked it, but I
didn't know exactly why.
And it was a little strange.
And I didn't really know why.
But one day, I was really
carefully looking at it.
And even though I had studied
this species for decades
of my life, I learned
something completely brand new
that was right in front
of me the whole time.
I was looking at it,
and I was looking--
if everybody can
see-- does everybody
see the eye of that lizard?
And I looked at the
eye really carefully.
I realized that eye
wasn't an eye at all.
And in fact, the eye
is above that eye.
You see the slit?
And I realized that
without knowing it
for all those years--
looking at this photo,
working with this species-- that
this lizard in the California
desert had invented the
first pair of sunglasses.
And literally, the
reason that this lizard
has this particular pattern
underneath its eye--
it closes its eye.
And if you think
about it, if you
live in an extreme environment,
like a desert, that's
incredibly arid-- intense
heat, intense cold-- your eyes
are sensitive.
They're wet.
And this lizard basically
pulls up the shades.
And it does it in a way that
predators would think that they
were still being watched.
We're lucky.
We have an incredible
national park
system in the United States.
And maybe more importantly,
maybe just more to appreciate,
is that that
national park system
has been the genesis of the
creation of national parks
across the world.
When people think about
our beautiful parks
and think about this
100 years of protecting
these remarkable places, people
think of places like the Grand
Canyon, pictured here.
It's an incredible chasm
shaped by water and by ice.
Or people think of Denali.
Denali is a mountain that
is so big and so vast,
that when you see
it-- I remember
the first time I saw Denali.
I was at a campground
called Wonder Lake.
And it's a hell of a
time to just get there.
And when you get there,
you stay there for a while.
And I stayed there for a while.
And I saw the mountain
emerge, and it
was the most amazing thing
that I had ever seen.
And then I realized I had only
seen the bottom third of it.
And when the rest
of it unshrouded,
I understood that I had
never seen a mountain before.
And I understood why people
called Denali the great one.
And I think about these
parks, these monuments
to ice, to mountains to
rock, to vibrancy and life,
like Redwood.
I think about the sequoias.
I think about the
desert that I live in.
And I think about the inherent
balance in the universe where
a giant mountain range bisects--
14,000-foot peaks run north
to south.
On one side, the
greatest trees to ever
live on the planet Earth
because of the moisture
that's dropped,
on the other side,
an incredible desert with the
oldest living animals, plants
on the planet.
In addition to the
remarkable places,
the exposition, the
geography, that's
protected by our national
parks- and before I go on,
let me just say that in talking
about our national parks
and talking about the
history of our parks,
it's not just the protection
of natural landscapes
of our natural history
that makes them special.
What our national
parks do, in fact,
is they tell the
story of America.
And that story of America
includes the story
of our prehistory, of
our geological history,
of our natural history, of
our evolutionary history,
our biological
history, but also,
telling some of the very
difficult stories of America
and of what it means to be
American-- some of the very
difficult times that we've
come through as a country, some
of the terrible mistakes
that we've made.
I, for example,
think about Manzanar.
I think about the incarceration
of American citizens
in camps looking out
across the eastern Sierra.
To imagine being an
American citizen,
and because of your ethnicity,
a war happens with the country
that you come from, and
you're forced, then,
to live in a concentration camp.
Our national parks also
tell those stories.
In addition to the protection
of these great places
and these great
stories, there's also
the protection of
incredible life and life
that may have otherwise
not been protected.
And I spend my spare time
as a wildlife photographer,
and I'd like to
show you guys a few
of those species that
exist now because
of the protection of
our national parks--
the additive value,
the amplification.
I met this particular grizzly
bear in coastal Alaska.
But the organization
that I work for,
the National Parks
Conservation Association,
is doing work to protect grizzly
bears across the country.
And I think about the bears
that live in the lower 48.
And without Yellowstone
and Glacier National Park,
there would be no grizzly
bears left in the lower 48.
So in addition to
being sanctuaries
of culture and
sanctuaries of story,
our national parks are also
refugia-- the last places
for the last species,
including some of the greatest
extant living animals
on our planet,
like this incredible bear.
I saw this bear take a
salmon that was this big
and eat it in two bites.
Because he wanted to.
This is a musk ox.
Musk ox is a species
that's represented now--
in the Pleistocene, there
were four species of musk ox.
There's only one left.
And I saw this one in Bering
Land Bridge in Alaska,
which is one of the
last places that you can
find this particular species.
This is, I think, the
species that people--
the reason that people like this
the most is because I think it
reminds them of "Star Wars."
But for me, I like
them because they
have this incredible response.
They are always fearful of
being eaten by polar bears
or being eaten by wolves.
And so they've developed
this strategy, which
is they put all their young
in the middle of a circle,
and they all circle up, horns
out, to protect their young.
I think about the natural
processes that have happened,
that have evolved over
time in North America.
And maybe nothing is more
powerful than the thought
of the salmon run.
Where I think about it,
the nerdy biologist in me
comes out all the time.
But it's to think about
these structures for bringing
nutrients from the deep
ocean back to land,
that in the trees that you
find along salmon streams,
the protein actually
builds forests.
And to think about that
distribution and redistribution
of resources and
how vital that is,
and that those processes
have developed over all time,
and that we're lucky enough,
at least in some places,
to still have that,
to enjoy that.
This really cute hawk lives
in Soberania National Park,
which is in Panama.
This particular hawk is
exceedingly endangered.
And farmers look at
it as a nuisance,
because it eats goats, just
picks them up and takes them
away.
And its natural prey
source is usually monkeys.
So this eagle, if you
can believe it or not,
it has short wings,
lives in the high canopy,
and it snatches monkeys out of
trees if you can believe that.
And while it's a bad
day for a monkey--
and I think we can all agree
that monkeys are cool--
the protection of these
great species is profound.
And it makes life richer.
It makes the content of the
world we live in richer.
I'll never forget the day
that I met my first Jaguar.
And these jaguars were hunting
capybaras down by a river.
And they were day hunting.
And so I was in a boat, and
I was photographing one.
And then I heard
[MAKES FOOTFALL  NOISES].
Don't worry.
It wasn't a jackhammer.
It was a capybara on a cliff.
And it jumped off of a
cliff into the river,
and it screamed.
And one second later, a
really pissed off Jaguar
was at the top of the
cliff, looking down.
These things are still happening
all over the world because
of an American concept
that was exported
that said we want to tell the
full stories of the world we
live in.
And now we're celebrating
our 100th anniversary.
And happy anniversary to you.
This is a photo I took.
And to me, it's the
transition of the desert.
Because I found
this tiny species
in the Australian desert.
And it's the ecological
analog to our horned lizard.
So it's thinking about
how resources in places
actually create species.
You see a leopard
and you see a jaguar.
You see a green tree python,
and you see an emerald tree boa.
You see a thorny devil, and
you see a horned lizard.
The resources that
are present actually
create shapes in nature,
like an incredible play-doh
that the environment
itself acts on the world
to create the shapes.
Folks don't think about
it, but roughly 30%
of the lands on planet
Earth are desert.
And the distribution
of those deserts
are very similar along
the lines of latitude.
You see those
lines going across?
It goes through the majority
of-- 30 degrees north goes
through the majority of
deserts on the planet.
And that's because of ocean--
basically currents and wind
patterns, and where rain is
brought and where it's not.
But to think of--
I think the desert
is probably the
most misunderstood
and underappreciated landscape,
terrestrial biome on planet
Earth.
It's a place, I think, where
people generally characterize
it by what it isn't.
It isn't a place
with giant trees.
It isn't a place with
abundant rivers or greenery.
But what it is is
it's a place that
has been acted on
by these pressures,
and these pressures have
created spectacular innovation,
the type of innovation
where-- and I'll show you.
Things are happening on a
global scale that are sometimes
difficult to comprehend.
And things that we're
still-- as we think
of, say, the rainforest and
the medicine that lives there,
and the species that
live there, we're
still coming to understand
why the desert matters
and what a big role it
plays on the planet.
So I don't think that I would
have to convince anybody
that the rainforest is one
of the most important--
it's the lungs of our planet.
And for us to live and be
sustainably on this planet,
we have to protect
that rainforest.
What if I told you that
the rainforest exists
in the way and shape it does
because of the Sahara Desert?
That's the case.
So you can see this picture
here from NASA, the good folks
over there at NASA.
You can see here this satellite
image of the winds coming off
of the Sahara being blown
across the Atlantic Ocean
and landing in the
Amazonian rainforest.
And I guess the
question that you
would ask yourself is
why does that matter
that the sand is being blown.
Or sand is being blown-- cool.
What does that mean?
Well, that sand, even
though the grains of sand
might be a tenth
of a millimeter,
they contain phosphorus.
And that phosphorous is actually
used for the growth and health
of the rainforest itself.
There is an incredible
interwoven tapestry
of this entire planet.
And again, we're just coming
to start to understand that.
This is as nerdy as I'll
get, and I promise that.
But I just wanted to
show you that in terms
of the amount of species
of anyplace on the planet,
only tropical savannas have
more species of animals
than deserts do.
And so what's known
to science today
is that there is something
like almost 8,000 species--
just animals-- in the
deserts of the world.
And that's more than
tropical forests.
That's more than grasslands,
than the temperate zones.
And deserts are
probably also the most
under-studied and under-explored
places on the planet,
meaning that the opportunity
to learn more and to find more
and for people who grew up
like I did, wanting desperately
to be an explorer, that
that opportunity still
exists in the world.
If you want to be
Indiana Jones--
This is perhaps the most famous
picture of a desert animal
ever taken, this
National Geographic
photo by Chris Johns.
And it shows the majesty of
a black-maned lion fighting
the elemental nature
of the desert.
It's these stark things.
It's power versus power.
When you think
about the desert, I
think people-- we talked a
lot about, say, reptiles,
or we talked about
other types of animals.
But the reality is that
if you think about deserts
on this planet, the
majority of mammals
that you find in any type
of ecosystem regularly
live in the desert.
So if you think
of a tiger, there
are tigers that live
in Indian deserts.
There are lions that
live in deserts.
The grizzly bears that
lived in the San Bernardino
Mountains used to come
down off of those mountains
into the California desert.
Elephants live in the desert.
So while I think we have
a notion about the value
of deserts, the reality is
that life on this planet
is well adapted to deserts.
And that specialization
has happened on a long-term
and on a short-term basis.
This is a picture of Death
Valley National Park.
And Death Valley National
Park is, I think, well
known as a land of extremes.
But it's also one of the
most beautiful places
on planet Earth.
And it's a place where the
raw geology of the planet
is surfaced.
There's not that many
places where you can walk
on a 2 billion year old rock.
And there's not many places
where you can find a plant,
a tree that's 6,000
years old, or a bush,
or a humble bush that's four
feet tall that had been around
since the Egyptians were
doing some stuff that
isn't happening right now.
When I talk about the
California desert,
I want to give you guys the
context of this landscape.
The California desert
is remarkably large.
It's about a fifth of
the state of California.
And it's roughly the
size of Virginia.
Also, if you look at
the green dots in here,
those are three of the now
four national parks that exist
within the California desert.
It's a land with-- I think
it's characteristically--
I think when people think
of the California desert,
they think of sand dunes.
I think people
think of-- really,
when people are thinking
of the California desert,
they're actually
thinking of the Sahara
and what they've seen on TV.
But in fact, the
California desert
is an incredibly rocky place.
And it's a place with
huge mountain ranges,
and mountain range
after mountain range
after mountain range.
It's a place where,
in the 1800s,
folks tried to introduce
camels, but the camels
couldn't make it,
because it was too rocky.
It's that kind of landscape.
It's just an endless
basin and range,
geology with an incredibly
diverse range of life.
This photo here-- if you look at
the various colors that exist,
this is an area that goes
from almost LA up to Utah.
And it shows the Mojave Desert.
And it shows, in
these various colors,
all the lands that are
protected within that landscape.
The California
desert is, in fact,
the most protected
landscape in the lower 48.
It's a big landscape.
It's in incredible condition.
I'll show you.
As you get more towards
the color green,
you can see-- this is
basically showing what's left
that's pristine in the country.
And when you look at where
the greatest concentration
of dark and light
green converge,
that happens in the
California desert
stretching into central Nevada.
There are some other
really well-protected areas
in the country, but nothing to
that extent, and nothing where
you can draw a line
700 miles or 800 miles
and have a contiguous
landscape like that.
And a contiguous landscape like
that means a lot of things.
It means that
species that migrate
are able to still migrate,
as they have for thousands
of years, that the
anthropogenic change has not
been intense on that landscape.
And for our California desert,
that's really happened.
Recently, it's happened due
to really good planning.
But for so long before
that, it was really
that people hadn't
found a use for it.
And when you think of our
desert, our California desert,
and you compare it to
deserts across the world,
our California desert
is in the best shape
of any desert on the planet.
And it's one of the most
protected and connected
landscapes on planet Earth.
And I think when people
would think about
that, they would think about
the Congo or the Amazon.
They wouldn't necessarily
think of the California desert.
But industrial
activities have really
only taken place in
the California desert
for less than 100 years.
And real industrialization
has probably only really taken
place for about 50 years.
So we're talking
about, as we talk
about the conservation
of this landscape, which
is the effort to which I spend
my full life, to understand
and protect this desert,
that maybe this is
a different kind of story.
Maybe this isn't the
story of what would it
have been like if we had only
gotten here at this time.
In this place, I think we're
making decisions today.
And we're making
decisions every day
about what the future
of this landscape
is going to look like.
And there's been a tremendous
amount of positive momentum
and action that's taken place.
There are right now-- and
I'll show you some maps--
but there's roughly 10 million
acres of contiguous protection
that exists in the
California desert,
making it the second
largest protected desert
reserve on the planet in our
beautiful California desert.
The desert is humbling.
The desert is also a place where
many people go to find spirit.
It's a difficult place,
certainly in summer.
And it is like the
Arctic in many ways
where there are long
stretches of harshness
and then incredible, short,
ephemeral times of bounty
where, in the Arctic, everything
becomes blueberries or salmon
run up streams, or in
the California desert,
where once you do a
hike, and the hike goes
through a beautiful, rugged,
elemental, brown country,
and you do that hike
again after a wet spring,
and the entire world is flowers.
This year, we had a
remarkable spring.
We had a remarkable
bloom in Death Valley.
And it had a different
type of composition
than any I had ever seen.
And one of those things
was called verbena.
Verbena is a small,
beautiful, purple flower.
And verbena has this
wonderful smell.
And I was camping
on a dry lake bed,
because that's just something
you do in the desert.
And there were these
guys who were basically
using these self-propelled--
I don't know exactly what you
call them, but they were
basically personal helicopters.
You get a running start.
You turn the motor on.
That's why they were
on the dry lake bed.
And you get up in the air.
And they were way up in the air.
And when the guy came down,
he looked like he was lost.
And I was like, hey,
are you all right?
Do you need water?
And he said, I just had
a spiritual experience.
I was up about 2,000 feet above
that large mountain range.
It was a mountain range
called the Kingston Mountains.
That's a 7,000-foot
tall mountain.
And he was flying over it.
And on one side of it is an
entire sand dune complex.
That was completely covered.
So the whole sand dunes was
covered in this purple flower,
this verbana.
And he said as I flew
over the mountain,
all I could smell was verbana.
And it had never occurred to me.
Where do those oils go that
are carried in the wind?
Where are they carried?
Where are those
seeds carried to?
They're carried all
across that desert.
There's just so much to learn.
And there's so much-- I think
the contrast in the desert
of the harshness
and the fragility
is profound, artistic,
spiritual, whatever
you want to call it.
It's poignant.
I arrived in the
California desert in 2008.
And in 2008, shortly thereafter,
myself, my colleagues,
the coalition of folks that I
work with started on an effort
to protect the greatest
connected landscape
in the lower 48.
And you can see here on
these colors-- basically,
the light green are the
national park lands.
And just north where it says
Fort Irwin, just north of that,
Death Valley National
Park connects north
from Mojave National Preserve.
This is an incredibly
large landscape
we're talking about,
going from almost--
we're talking about
50 miles to the border
all the way up to
Bishop, California.
That's how far north and
south we're talking about.
We started an effort that was
community focused but also
political to take wild
places that really, really
needed protection and to
start sharing that with folks
and working to get
people to understand
why these places mattered and
what could be done about it.
And I'm so glad to be able
to be here with the good news
to let you guys know that after
nearly a decade of work, so
much effort, strife,
discussions, thousands
and thousands and
thousands of hours,
we were able to get to
a point where we were
unable to pass legislation.
We had a bill to
protect these lands.
We couldn't get Congress
to do the right thing.
And we asked the President if
he would do the right thing.
And in February, he did, and he
designated 1.8 million acres.
And this map here
shows those lands.
And those lands will
be protected forever.
And I'm going to
walk you through
these different monuments
so you can get to know them.
They're better in person.
Unless you get me in
advance, I'm probably not
going to able to narrate them
for you while you're there.
You guys hate jokes.
So the gray down at
the bottom, that's
Sand to Snow National Monument.
I want to walk you
through that a little bit.
This is an aerial photo of
Sand to Snow National Monument.
And it's special for
a lot of reasons.
And the name is literal.
Because it stretches
from 1,500 feet
sand up to 10,000 feet in snow.
And as national monuments go,
this one is the most diverse
in terms of the life zones
that it goes through.
It goes through six
different life zones.
And you can imagine what that's
like going from-- you actually
go from the Sonoran Desert
to the Mojave Desert,
because that's where the
deserts come together.
And the Mojave Desert is
a higher, colder desert.
Then you start
moving up into Aspen.
You start moving up
into fur, yellow pine.
You almost get to tree line
in this national monument.
You can see in the
very background
San Gorgonio, the highest
point in Southern California,
which is part of that
national monument.
The foreground are the little
San Bernardino Mountains.
And the little San
Bernardino Mountains
are the mountainous shield
that mark the transition
from the Coachella Valley,
where Palm Springs is, up
to Joshua Tree National Park.
These are ocotillos, which
are found in the lower Sonoran
Desert, kind of the very bottom.
So Sand to Snow is really
important for wildlife
and for wildlife migrations.
There's really a place
in this national moment
that's really special to me.
It's called Big Morongo Canyon.
And Big Morongo Canyon is one
of the most important places
for birds in the entire
state of California.
And if you could
imagine being a bird
and flying over
harsh desert, and you
see an oasis of
cottonwood trees,
standing water, palms-- this is
where hundreds of bird species
come to nest, in
this, basically,
pocket, a pocket of water
that's created a forest.
Because the geology just--
there's a fault, water.
There's an underground river.
The fault hits that water
source, pushes it upwards.
Life-- just add water.
It's also a really, really
important place for folks
who spend time in the Sierra.
As folks who spend time
in the Sierra know,
the California mountains
get increasingly
dry as the year goes on.
So there is snow melt,
and there's abundance.
There's waterfalls in spring.
As you get into fall,
everything starts drying up,
and you start getting
wildfire danger.
And everything
almost gets crispy.
And at those times, those
perennial water sources
become even more important.
So you might be at
Big Morongo Canyon,
and it wouldn't be uncommon
to see a black bear down
at 2,000 feet in the middle of
the desert, just in his grove
in the middle of the desert.
You might be on a
boardwalk, and there
could be a black bear on
it-- or mountain lions,
or a big-horned sheep.
This is the cactus
wren, which has
one of the most beautiful
songs of any birds,
and which is characteristic
of the Mojave portion of Sand
to Snow.
And many people don't
know that the California
desert is actually a
really wonderful place
to see fall color.
And along the river
bottoms and the places
where you get
especially cottonwood,
you get outstanding fall color.
The second place I'm
going to talk to you
about is Mojave Trails
National Monument.
And that's this big,
white component.
It stretches all the
way down to Joshua Tree
National Park and up to
Mojave National Preserve.
For context, Mojave National
Preserve is 1.6 million acres.
It's the third largest
national park in the lower 48.
Mojave Trails, which
is now connected to it,
is also 1.6 million
acres connecting down
to Joshua Tree National
Park, which is 800,000 acres.
This is an aerial photograph.
It's incredible to
fly over the Mojave,
because you have the
opportunity to really see
the geological forces at work.
You'll see huge volcanic
fields, and you'll
see dry lake beds that were,
in the Pleistocene, home
to Native American villages
and to mammoths alike.
And you see oceans of sand
slowly taking over the land.
And when you're
flying over, you'll
see these mountain ranges.
And as you get high
enough, they almost
look like caterpillars
walking across the landscape.
Here you can see that
the sand is actually
covering the mountains.
And there was a bunch of places
where the mountain ranges are
actually buried in so much
sand that all you can see
is the little
crest of the peaks.
And those crests are
like islands in the sand.
And you think about that
on a geological level.
You think about how
much sand that is,
and how many years
that is, and how
remarkable that is that
there are mountain ranges
completely covered in sand
across the California desert.
Mojave Trails National
Monument is a place where
you get that kind of feeling.
This is one of the
lower mountain ranges.
And I'm just showing you this
because the lightest color
rock is actually an old fossil
bed from the Carboniferous
period, where people actually
go to find trilobites.
So people will go
with their pick axes,
and they'll pull out
these ancient sea
creatures from 350
million years ago
that are probably seeing the
light-- they're not seeing it,
obviously-- but they're seeing
the light for the first time
in a really long time.
The protection of
Mojave Trails also
protects almost a million acres
of critical desert tortoise
habitat, which is so
important, because number one,
it's super cool that we
have a desert tortoise.
In America, we have four
species of tortoises,
and one of those
lives in California.
It's our state reptile, and
it's an interesting and cool
species.
But to know that in
the last 20-plus years
that we've probably
lost 90% of them,
and then to know
that we've protected
over a million additional
acres of their habitat
is extremely important for the
perseverance of the species.
Just an important place
for large mammals--
for mountain lions, for
Coyotes, for bighorn sheep,
for mule deer.
They walk across these
grand landscapes.
And they don't really
have-- a species
that lives in a place
with abundant resources
might not have to cover
the same amount of ground
as a species in the desert does.
So to protect the larger
landscapes and the really
important water sources is
crucial to the well-being
of these creatures.
And throughout the Mojave, we
have these underground river
systems.
Here is the Mojave
River, which comes down
from the San
Bernardino Mountains
and ends at Mojave
National Preserve.
This is Amboy Crater, one
of the youngest lava fields
in the California desert.
It's home to an incredible
diversity of species.
And it's actually a laboratory,
an ecological laboratory.
Because the species
that live here
all exhibit melanism, which
means that they're darker.
So species that you'll find that
will be various colors when you
find them in the lava, they've
adapted to that environment,
and they've done
that really quickly.
And scientists from
all over the world
are coming to this
particular place
to figure out how they've
adapted so quickly.
That's the chuckwalla.
It's a two-foot-long
vegetarian lizard.
They're really social.
And they don't get
bitey aggressive,
but they get very territorial.
And when they get into breeding,
they'll come right up to you
and let you know that you should
not mess with their females.
The final monument that I
want to talk to you about--
and I'm going to stop very soon,
because I want to make sure
that we have time
for questions--
is this black piece in
Mojave National Preserve.
It's Castle Mountains
National Monument.
This is our newest
National Park Service unit.
This is the National Park
Service website for the unit,
just created this year.
And this is some original
art that NPCA produced
to celebrate and
commemorate the designation
of this remarkable landscape.
Let me tell you
why it's special.
At about 5,000 feet in the
very eastern Mojave Desert,
you get monsoonal
rain, which makes
it incredibly lush, and high
enough elevation that you
actually create an extremely
rare thing in the California
desert.
That's a grassland.
So this is an actual
grassland that
is hugged between two of
the most iconic mountain
ranges in the entire
California desert.
Because it's a grassland,
and because of its elevation,
and because of the amount
of moisture it gets,
it's super diverse.
And you get all kinds
of things happening here
that aren't happening
in other places.
The Joshua Tree-- so this
is the eastern termination
of the world's largest
Joshua tree forest.
And those Joshua trees
are riddled with life.
There are all kinds
of animals using them,
including red tail hawks
which nest in them.
And we were out here
recently on a tour,
and there were
baby red tail hawks
that were just learning to fly.
And we were able to
see these hawks doing
a really terrible
job of flying, but
in a ridiculous
and wonderful way
where they're flapping around,
they're hanging upside down.
And we were there as
the sun was setting,
and so we were watching
the silhouette of the hawks
as they're flapping around.
It's remarkable.
Here's a good look at the
extent of the grassland.
This is the most
intact grassland
left in the California desert.
And it was severely threatened,
and thankfully has just now
been protected,
just this February.
There are two herds
of bighorn sheep
that live here-- a
migratory herd that
goes around a large
set of mountains,
and then another one that stays
the entire year in the Castle
Mountains.
This is a good look
at the Castle Peaks.
They're volcanic in origin.
And a really good look at
the diverse Joshua tree
forest as well as the
different species of yucca
that live here.
Some of those yuccas
may be 1,000 years old.
The final goal that we
have for this landscape,
for the Castle Mountains,
is the reintroduction
of the pronghorn antelope.
So 100 years ago
on this grassland,
there were pronghorned antelope,
and there were Mexican wolves
that would hunt them.
And our first step
is to reintroduce
these pronghorned antelope,
and it's something
that we've wanted to
do for a very long time
but were unwilling
to do, because we
didn't know what the fate of
the landscape was going to be.
And now that it's protected,
it's our next step.
I'm going to end it here just
so we have time for questions,
but thank you guys so
much for listening to me
talk about the
California desert.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: One
question I would have
for you is if you could
explain to us some
of the difference
between a designation
of a national monument
versus a national park
and some of the other
possibilities the government
had with these lands,
that would be awesome.
DAVID LAMFROM: So I
think everybody knows
that government is simple.
There's so many different
agencies in the California
desert that manage land.
So there's different-- within
the Interior Department,
and within that
Interior Department,
there is the Bureau of
Land Management, which
is the largest landowner
in the entire country.
And they manage for
a specific purpose,
which is called multiple
use, which means
that they protect some lands.
Some lands are designated
for protection.
for recreation, et cetera.
The National Park
Service has less lands,
although they have a great
deal of lands in the California
desert.
The National Park Service has
a more conservation-focused
mission, and that mission is
to protect those resources that
exist there in perpetuity.
There are other
land managers that
are not in the
Department of Interior,
like the Forest
Service, for example,
which is in the
Department of Agriculture.
And there's also the
Department of Defense,
which owns something like
3 million acres of land
in the California desert.
So there's a lot of different
types of designations.
The national monuments
that I discussed-- Sand
to Snow and Mojave
Trails-- those
are both owned by the
Bureau of Land Management,
and they are being
protected for the protection
of their resources.
Castle Mountains is owned by
the National Park Service,
and is going to be protected in
perpetuity for the protection
of its resources.
So in both cases, they
have extremely high levels
of protection.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering how you
think about the future
of having people being
able to camp in these preserves
and in these national parks,
but also making sure that
they aren't destroying them
at the same time, and what you
think tourism in that sense
will be as we go on.
DAVID LAMFROM: I think that's
a really important question.
And it's a tough
thing for-- I think
that it's really easy to
look at it in this binary way
where the amount of people
who use something directly
correlates to the intensity
to which it is harmed.
I don't think that that's
necessarily the case.
And I think in many cases,
the more a person steps
foot on a place, the
softer their foot
becomes, because they
come to care about it.
They come to understand it.
And so I don't think that it's
really about the specific use.
I think it's about people
being open to understanding
what a place is, and why it
matters, and who it's for.
And the answer to who
it's for is for everybody,
and that matters.
And it's hard sometimes to
have the perspective of time
to think about who came before
and who will come after.
But I think it's a humble
and important thing for us
to think about.
And I think that ultimately,
we have to show people,
and not in a judgey way, or not
in a restrictive, necessarily,
way.
But just about being-- I
think that there's nothing
more compelling to me than
people who love things.
And so if we have
genuine stewards
in places who care
about places, I
think we will have those places.
AUDIENCE: And maybe
what you have observed
and what you are
observing currently,
and maybe what would be
your hopes for the future,
and the two sides of
it-- how technology
gets to separate
people from nature,
and as you said, what
we don't directly know,
and I think that we don't
directly engage with.
Maybe we don't really
feel the need to protect.
And the other side--
how technology may help
to-- completely the opposite.
We establish that connection.
DAVID LAMFROM: I think that's
a really wonderful question,
and I think there's
a lot of answers.
There's a lot of ways that
we could discuss this.
But there's a couple of, I
think, really immediate points.
One is it's an incredibly
privileged position
to have the Earth sustain you,
to have food, to have water,
to have everything
you need, and then
to say I don't need nature.
It's a very privileged
place to be.
And I don't think it's
about people having
to reconnect to
nature, or that people
have disassociated from nature.
I think it's that continuum
that I was discussing before,
which is if you think-- if we
all think back-- and some of us
don't even have the privilege
of knowing-- I don't know--
I can't go that far back
in my own family tree
and know exactly what my
distant relatives did.
I have no idea.
But a couple generations ago,
we were all fundamentally
connected to the land.
And understanding who we
are and where we came from
is a function of understanding
that we came from the land.
And it's not about--
I think it's not
about certain good Samaritans
showing folks, hey, let
me show you how to be outside.
Let me take you hiking.
Let me teach you how to camp.
It's about people
understanding themselves
and where they come from.
And I don't think every person
has to be an environmentalist.
Or maybe every person doesn't
even enjoy being outside.
But I think that you
have to understand
that you're on this
planet, and you
have to understand
your place on it,
and that you have a
profound privilege.
We, at least, have this
incredible privilege.
And part of that is being
respectful of that world.
Now, when you think
about and talk
about people who are
being disconnected
due to technology-- so I just
think that because people-- I
think people inherently
care about nature.
Cat videos, animals-- people
are drawn instinctively,
inherently to living creatures
on the Earth and to the Earth
itself.
And when people think about
themselves in beautiful places,
they think about these places.
It's a deep part of our ethos.
So we are connected.
And so if I thought about
the lines of disconnection,
I don't think that they're
really that far apart.
And I frankly think
that technology can,
if we're open to it-- I
think it's just about us
being humbled.
But I think if we're open to it,
technology can help us enjoy.
I just saw today there was
an app, a Shazam for plants,
where you take a
picture of a plant,
and your phone is going to
tell you what that plant is.
Because I still
use a typewriter,
I wasn't the guy to invent that,
but I think that's awesome.
It's easy to it's easy to
assume that we are very far,
but we're not.
We are here.
We are a part of this
thing that's happening.
And I think that really,
people have to take a moment.
I think if you just really
calmly think about yourself
and your place on
this Earth, you
understand that you're connected
to all of these systems.
We are plugged into the
natural world in way
more ways than we're plugged
into the internet or our phones
or any of these things.
AUDIENCE: Are there
similar efforts
to protect these deserts in
the other states in the west--
in Arizona, Nevada,
Idaho, Wyoming, Utah,
as you described in California?
DAVID LAMFROM: There are
multiple and discreet efforts
across the West in deserts and
in mountains to protect really,
really precious places.
I don't think that
there's anything--
there is, I think, something
of this scale that's
being thought about in the
state of Utah right now.
Beyond that, I don't
think that there's
anything of this magnitude
that has been envisioned.
And for me, what's
really remarkable
is that we got there, that we
had the foresight to protect.
That's a wild and vast land.
But there are efforts.
Efforts are ongoing.
But the reality is
there's more to do.
There's a tremendous amount of
really, really special places.
But for these efforts
to actually work,
they have to be authentic.
And they have to be driven
by people who know the places
and love the places.
So I don't think that
conservation should not--
that's not the right word.
Conservation for its
own sake has value,
but it's best when done
by people who love places
to care for those places.
Otherwise, it becomes
politics or a game.
And that may take us farther
away from where we want to be,
which is to really help
people understand these places
and why they matter.
MATT SHEETS: Thank
you so much, David.
We really appreciate it.
And thank you, everyone,
for coming today.
[APPLAUSE]